c'est quelque chose que tu érotique
rapporte 1
tous
pertes comme tu sais qui a rien après la
forêt je le sais c'est tout cheyrou mais
un seul pied en dehors de la forêt on
disparaît pour toujours qu'est ce qui
lui est arrivé à tomber il a versé du
toi je te présente ma fille elle
s'appelle manon et moi ma nage il a pas
peur pour toi ton père si bien il le
sait pourtant que loeb remporte les
jeunes filles pour les enfermer dans sa
forêt maudite m'a mordu
tu l'avais de l'amour pour toi il serait
pas comme ça au ghetto il sera guéri il
va repartir dans la forêt avec toi et
nous conduira plus jamais que sauf si je
le retrouve
tu te retrouves qui font l'amour
et à ton âme
mais
par là des fantômes c'est la croix que
pour amener à huy